hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chances.com so in this video guys as
usual we're going to start with a market
update on amc and gme then i want to
talk about quickly triple q twitter
utter and i want to show you as well uh
the two indicators that for me are very
important today which are the us 10 new
yield and the dxy and i'm gonna tell you
why so let's get into it
and guys as usual let's start with amc
so yesterday uh i was telling you guys
that
we were still on the first time frame
having this um kind of situation
that looks like a reversal situation
because we can see the move down is
slowing once again as can be seen on the
momentum
uh
macd going higher even here we still
have the bullish divergence on macd we
lost the bullish divergence on the rsi
okay so once again momentum going higher
price action going lower so this is
usually a situation uh where we can
expect a reversal especially if we have
a nice consolidation so as you can see i
did my video i think around here and i
was spotting this wedge pattern so
um today what happened as usual guys we
opened the day with some hope and we got
rejected at the 16.3
resistance level
uh which is
is this trendline good yeah okay well we
didn't even touch this trend line uh
this upper band uh and for now we are
rejected so we are below the 16.3 level
which was our last support uh being the
breakout level uh before 13 and um and
we broke out below this uh trend line
here which was forming the wedge lower
band
so it's not looking good uh we lost the
bullish divergence here we still have
the british divergence on the macd and
same thing as we are still waiting
for you know bulls to do some something
finally and to manage to have at least
guys a breakout above this trend line
which i believe will give us
um a nice buddhist reaction let's see
how high this can go once again as long
as we are in a bearish environment on
the global market you guys know you guys
have seen that amc and gme cannot fight
it by themselves so we need the global
market to look better for those stocks
to uh have the energy to reverse and
finally for bulls to take back control
so for now bears and control
uh and once again we are waiting for uh
close a daily close above this trend
line which is right now around around
16.3 so let's see what's going to happen
here what else can i tell you guys
um
[Music]
nothing
let's go on a daily time frame quickly
what do we have max is still going lower
on the daily
not much information here on the hourly
time frame what do we have you can see
those volume guys
lower and lower and lower i mean you
know
so it just means that you know there is
not a lot of trading on amc compared to
what it has been before
uh it's good and bad it means that you
know investors lost interest which is
not good but it means also that uh
whenever bulls are going to start to
come back
we know what they're capable to do right
uh capable of doing because we've seen
the volume involved whenever mc starts
to uh rip and
if only we have one day of this bias
coming back it will be enough to destroy
every bear that is standing between the
16 and i would say
you know 19. we'll probably go to 19
easily above 19 we would need to see so
for now we don't have the reversal we
are waiting for it so let's see once
again we need a close above 16.3 for
both to take back control
jimmy
so gme uh has fulfilled the prophecy
which is which was
going to the 61.8 percent fib ratio as
you can see it was 124 today we had a
bounce at
224.5
so somehow you know it so of course all
right the charts are not looking good
guys but you know i'm always trying to
find the good thing in um
in the information i have from the price
action here the good thing i see
is that at least this target has been
reached and maybe buzz will finally let
go but once again guys we need a
comeback on the global market so let's
have a look at that and for now we don't
have it so let me quickly remind you
guys what i was saying here i told you
that 3 19 3 sorry 318 was support it has
been
um crossed yesterday on increasing
volume so that's
you know that's a breakout let's be
honest
uh that's a breakout but we didn't have
this consideration before just like we
had here which gives energy to the move
so for now i would say that
um
you know we could break it but most
likely and this is what i said this
morning in my discord
bam bam bam
i said that uh we arrived on 318 support
we might see a debt cat bounce today all
right a dead cat bounce why which means
the market is you know bouncing but
quickly uh getting sold um
because whenever you arrive on a support
that has not been touched for quite some
times so
for quite some time sorry you often have
this bullish reactions um but you often
have as well early profit taking so
let's zoom in a little bit on the hourly
timeframe
you're going to understand what is
happening so let's see maybe we're going
to
finally manage to make this reversal
here as well on the our timeframe guys
same technique you make a trend line so
at the beginning the trendline has only
two reactions one two then here this
morning we had a third reaction here
then fourth fifth and now we are
fighting this level so here we have
clearly a nice consolidation that is
taking place just below the strain line
which gives energy to the potential move
to come but for now bears and control
here
this was uh strong
[Music]
this room this was a strong signal sent
by the best which is that they managed
to went through this level all right we
closed below 3 18 yesterday so bears are
strong right and they made the point so
right now oh look guys maybe this is the
rebound we are waiting for so let's see
let's see what's gonna happen here but
maybe we're gonna be able to have this
bounce if we do have that
so let's find out very soon
it's looking nice for now
we might have still a dead cat bounce i
believe but a little bit uh longer which
means that we would probably
sorry bam
would probably manage to uh you know
have a nice rebound maybe so it's let's
let's see where are the resistances
level here is this trend line still
valid
all right
the streamline is not too bad
okay because you can see this trendline
is not too bad because whenever we went
through it we had a strong move so this
trendline was acting as support as you
guys know after support has been broken
it's acting as resistance so here i see
resistance at 3 30 and then 338 so
basically this whole area is for me an
area uh to actually sell for those who
have a long position not financial
advice but
i'm personally flatish on this market i
even made some money yesterday
because i'm having a decent short
position on triple cube it's protecting
the rest of my investments
i'm not taking profits here once again
because i don't want to lose this
protection because i know that things
can go fast in this area i'm
unfortunately afraid we go to 280 guys i
explained that yesterday
but if we manage to have this breakout
above this trend line so for now we are
getting rejected again but let's see
maybe we're going to manage to break it
before the end of this video then we're
probably going to go to the streamline
330 and from here probably rejected if
you manage to go higher probably reset
it here so even if we have here a dead
cat bounce that can be a little bit
higher than only that it can you know be
a plus five percent as i still think
that bears are in control as long as we
are below
338 so i would personally uh as i am
neutral right now if i was long i would
take some uh i mean i would take some
short position here on triple q
um
or yeah i would just take some short
position here i would add here and i
would add here as i am
roughly neutral i don't want to take the
risk to take a short position here when
i know this market can go here and still
be bearish so i only gonna build a new
short position around this area so maybe
330 i'm gonna take a little bit of shot
let's see i'm gonna let you know guys
for those who are with me in discord for
now i don't do anything today is a quiet
day for me i didn't trade anything uh
yesterday as well guys i'm a bit in the
wait and see mode um wait and see what
you're gonna see what i'm paying
attention to guys i want to talk about
twitter and utter uh but very quickly
i'm not gonna spend too much time on
that guys i explained that yesterday for
those who have not watched my video go
check what i said about the u.s 10-year
yield but very quickly it is a good
indicator of
incoming big crisis all right uh if we
stay below
285 uh on friday so the day after
tomorrow we are wednesday right yeah um
if we close above 285 on friday this
would be a second weekly close above
this
resistance line that is a 30 years a 40
years resistance line guys it would
really not send a good signal to the
market all right and this is due to
inflation and once again it is
the expected the 10 the u.s 10-year
yield can be seen as the expected return
of the market which means that companies
need to beat 2.8 of return on the um on
their businesses to attract investors so
the higher it is the tougher it is uh
for investors i mean the less
interesting it is for investors to go to
the equity market so they usually sell
the equity uh when we are in an
inflationary environment which is the
case right now the second indicator guys
that i have not shown you for quite some
time but i always keep an eye on this
one dxy we can go on a weekly time frame
guys we are trying to you know i'm
trying here to use some indicators
uh on the long term to try to guess if
we are only in the correction or if we
enter a real bear market and for now
guys
you might think that triple q
is cheap
i can tell you that we
we can easily have more downside if
things turn really bad so for now this
is not cheap for me once again i would
personally not load a long position on
triple q or on the rest of the market
before 280 alright because i think that
280 is gonna start to be cheap for now
it is not cheap and what i'm paying
attention to to know if if we could even
go below 280 is
once again u.s 10-year yield and dxy why
the xy guys because dxy the dollar index
is a very good indicator to measure the
fear that is in the market why fear
because when people are scared you guys
know that all the debt is labeled is um
denominated in dollars u.s dollars so
whenever
we arrive in an environment with with
tensions just like right now because of
the wall
and because of the covey that is
creating a lower growth in the whole
world and you know that is just not good
for business
we usually see a rush for the dollar you
can see each time we had a crisis i mean
you know strong move down of the market
dxy was at 103 all right here covet
crisis sorry this was the when we
increased the rates in 2016 that gave us
a
a correction a big correction on the
global market you can have a look
uh this was the covet crisis and this is
now so something is telling me that
maybe you know the scenario that could
make sense is that this is just the end
of the correction and that we're just
going to get rejected here
rejected here sorry
and
rebound right
sorry
bam and rebound maybe maybe
i wish i don't know i wish but this is
something possible but on the other hand
what makes me think that this is a
possible scenario is that we arrive here
very extended as you can see the rsi is
flying around 78 guys so very high rsi
um
[Music]
and we arrive on this resistance that
has not been touched for
two years all right so usually when we
arrive on a resistance that has not been
touched for two years we get a selling
reaction especially when we are extended
which means we don't have any
consolidation we have one here but it's
quite far
and we are basically moving strongly
higher without taking a break so
if i only pay attention to dxy my take
is that we get rejected which means that
it is bullish for the market
uh but on the other hand
if we have really some structure
structural reasons because of the fear
once again dxy is um an asset that
investors will go to whenever they are
scared right scared of what i don't know
but just scared you know they want to
have us dollars because they feel this
is the best currency to hold at the
moment to pay back the debt if they are
if they are indebted if it's like a
foreign country
whatever the reason the dollar is just
giving confidence to people it's like a
strong um
a strong currency right so
uh if we really have those structural
issues that make the dxy
uh
break out here i think if we have a
breakout it will be a massive one all
right i think it can it can do plus five
percent in in a matter of one day this
would be just you know exponentially
going higher
and if we enter this territory
here i can bet everything you want that
we would break out as well and
the global market would probably go to
280 quickly guys yesterday we did minus
four percent it was a long time we
didn't do a minus four percent on the
nasdaq it reminds me guys
what was happening here right
here we did i think minus four something
like that minus five all right so the
last time was in september 20 yes it was
a long time it didn't happen
when those things that didn't happen for
a long time suddenly happen it's not
good right because it reminds everybody
bad memories so investors are scared
they don't want to buy the deep whenever
you know they remind they remember some
bad things so once again it doesn't mean
for sure we're gonna break out here
below that level um
but i see a dark scenario guys where
basically dxy is breaking out above 103
and u.s 10 year yield is breaking out
above 285 if i see that
and triple 2 is not at 280 yet guys i
think that wherever we are i'm gonna you
know take a short position because this
would be really bad
okay i don't want to
think about what could happen with amc
and jme if this happens but guess it
would not be good we'll probably go to
13 all right
um
but we're not yet and we have a very
reasonable scenario where we just get
rejected here once again get rejected
here
and have a strong rebound on the equity
market so let's hope this is what is
waiting for us uh tomorrow and friday
now i want to talk quickly about twitter
as you guys know elon musk um both
twitter alright at 54 i think so not a
very good trade for now
the question is should we jump in this
trade um
i mean i discussed that a little bit
with some members in my discord and
um
i mean i don't see
the reason to rush into twitter right
now
when we have a clear resistance line why
is it clear one two three reactions
that has
a resistance at let's say 59
but it's going lower so maybe 58 in a
few months
so i prefer to buy twitter at 60
whenever we have some bullish signals
all right
rather than buying it at 50 which is
20 percent lower roughly
and having a high probability of
rejection because guys we have a gap
here i mean the global market is bearish
so i would personally not jump in this
trade i would wait for more clarity i
would wait for a breakout above uh
roughly 56 60. we can also draw another
trend line that is coming here but this
trend line has only two reactions one
two i mean three now
um so it's not a strong trend line it's
still acting as resistance right now so
maybe if we break out first below that
you can make i mean a long position here
stop loss here and try to play you know
to buy a little bit earlier but once
again guys i mean there's no rush right
we have time the market is not gonna
suddenly rally and never come back right
we're gonna have the usual you know ups
and downs with some pullbacks with some
nice opportunity to buy in a few months
twitter at i believe a price that is not
much higher than now and we're gonna be
in the bull market i mean if we are i
don't know but i mean if we are there
gonna be some nice opportunities to buy
it here i put that in my alerts and i'm
going to post that of course whenever i
see it
last one today guys atter
uh atter was a stock that um
that is behaving very well guys uh all
right we almost reached the target i
sure gave my discord a buying signal and
the target was at the beginning 5 40 50
then 7 30 and we went to 7
29 or 26 right so we missed the target
for a little then we got stopped here
uh so right now
i can clearly see that the 20-day moving
average acted here well as a support so
we can expect this to act again as
support so maybe if we come back to 450
there is a nice trade to take
by 450 stop loss let's say four
and just hope that we hold above this
20-day moving average
and once again i personally won't be
taking that trade because you know i
don't have time to take those day
trading positions on many stocks because
i don't have time to monitor everything
so i prefer to do some swing trading and
i here um
have a signal that will be triggered
whenever we break out above this trend
line right here so roughly above seven
but once again for this breakout to be
good quality those who have the course
know that we need to have a
consolidation on low volume and then the
breakout was increased in volume so
let's see if we're able to do that so my
preferred scenario would be that we just
you know oscillate here for you know a
few weeks even a few months and then
that we have a breakout here so this
would be kind of an easy trade all right
so this is what i'm personally paying
attention to
so that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys